it's safe to say that Walter Cronkite
was not the most trusted man in America
and it's safe to say he was not even the
most trusted man among newsman
I am Nikolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with joseph campbell he's
a professor of communications at
american university the author of the
great 2010 book getting it wrong Joe
thanks for talking with us thank you
thank you Nick
we're talking about Walter Cronkite
there's a new biography about Walter
Cronkite and it kind of trades in a
couple of cliches about Cronkite
specifically that he was the most
trusted man in America and that his
statement about how we couldn't win the
Vietnam War somehow turned the tide of
public opinion what's wrong with our
understanding of Walter Cronkite well we
tend to put Walter Cronkite on a
pedestal I mean he was an esteemed
newsman he was the the anchor for CBS
News for for many years from the early
60s until 1981 and there was a lot that
Walter Cronkite I mean he was a very
familiar figure in American households
but was he the most trusted man in
America you sure it wasn't I mean not
that he was distrusted it's just that
this is very difficult to assess talk a
little bit about what you know when
people were pushed to produce evidence
for how we knew this what what were what
was the survey that somehow dubbed him
the most trusted man this title this
this epithet can be traced to like 1972
and a survey done by quailing company in
18 states of some 8700 respondents
tested the the trust factor what they
called the trust factor of prominent
than prominent politicians Richard Nixon
Hubert Humphrey Spiro T Agnew real
sluggers row yeah yeah and and then they
they threw in Walter Cronkite's names
just sort of to sort of get a barometer
reading I guess and and and so compared
to these skunks yeah well we're concave
inevitably came up on top so then CBS
News use this survey the results of this
survey which clearly showed Cronkite
ahead of everybody else
I think the second place was the generic
US senators
and and you know richard nixon's way
dead and that the generic not ted
kennedy might have been down in the
early so I think I've been muskie
finished third in this in this ranking
but anyway CBS News takes the the survey
results and on the day of the election
in nineteen seventy two in November 1972
runs full-page ads and leading US
newspapers in New York Times Chicago
Tribune Washington Post saying reelect
the most trusted man in America and it
was a way that out Walter Cronkite is
that as the source to go to for election
coverage among the three networks and
and in polls of the actual network
anchors how did Cronkite do it
fluctuated there was a surveys done in
the early 70s by a polling organization
called Phillip singling ER and one year
you know Cronkite's number one and the
next year he's it's like number four
there are some fluctuation there's some
variation so it's it's safe to say that
Walter Cronkite was not the most trusted
man in America and it's safe to say he
was not even the most trusted man among
newsmen wrong anchorman in the early 70s
oh well let's talk about this you know
the apocryphal story that Lyndon Johnson
realizing after coverage of the Tet
Offensive he somehow says if I've lost
Cronkite I've lost America what's wrong
with that story which we all hear that's
right it's it's it's one of the
best-known anecdotes in american
american journalism and it is a leading
media myth it's a story that is that
it's delicious and appealing and wiley
told but on close inspection dissolves
as apocryphal or wildly exaggerated in
this case it's very clear lyndon johnson
didn't even see the program messiah that
we are mired in stalemate seems the only
realistic if unsatisfactory conclusion
and the myth has it that johnson watched
this show in the white house and upon
hearing Cronkite's declaration that the
US military effort is mired in stalemate
johnson leans over and snaps off the
television set and says something to the
effect of if I've lost Cronkite I've
lost middle America or if I've lost
Cronkite I've lost the war or have lost
the country the versions varied markedly
and that's you say that's a tell that in
fact there wasn't a single statement
because
there would be an actual quote rather
than these variation if if anyone's
precise words should be captured you'd
expect them to be the presidents we live
in a world where you know which is
saturated in media I mean people can
access information immediate from a wide
variety of sources at any time of day
you can push it you can pull it and
oddly the media often looks at this and
panics but is it harder now to I mean is
the the level of noise to information
higher than it used to be or you know or
is this a good time for media from a
consumers point of view or are we just
being fed lie after lie after lie you
know I think it is a good time for
consumers I mean back when Cronkite was
was on the air pontificating and so
forth
we had three options essentially three
Network News programs and now it's just
all kinds of options you know cable
over-the-air etc etc and online this
variety can propel media myths and in a
pretty profound and rapid way but the
but the variety of options also allows
for these myths to be knocked down
fairly quickly well I want to thank
Joseph Campbell for talking with reason
TV you are the author of getting it
wrong a professor at American University
Joe thanks for talking to Reason Nichols
a pleasure thank you and that's the way
it is